hi i'm wesley chun from the google cloud
team joined by my colleague martin to
welcome you to serverless migration
station
where each video shows developers one
modernization technique
for one of our serverless compute
platforms today our little friend porter
will take python 2 app engine developers
from cloud adb
to cloud datastore this is an optional
migration so you don't need to make this
journey unless you have a good reason to
do so
that sounds good wes but wait my time is
precious
why is this migration optional yeah
that's a very good question martin
well legacy python 2 app engine
developers have traditionally used app
engine's
ndb library to talk to datastore in the
previous module 2 video
we showed you how to move from app
engine ndb and app engine datastore
to cloud ndb in cloud datastore that
migration had one specific goal
modernizing app engine apps means moving
away from legacy services to unbundled
services
because the original services are
feature complete so all innovation
moving forward only comes with the newer
standalone services you can move to
python 3
the next generation app engine service
and that's why this additional migration
cloud data store is optional
by the way it's just app migration since
app engine datastore and cloud datastore
point to the same database in your
project
no data migration is needed review the
module 2 video and codelab to
re-familiarize yourself with our
starting point
the links bar below as well let's pause
for a moment to let you review before
moving on
because app engine datastore and cloud
datastore point to the same database in
your project
one great feature of that migration is
that you didn't have to migrate the data
only doing the app migration in the
video that's right
and not only did i watch that video i
helped you make it remember
anyway uh i know how to migrate from app
engine and db
to cloud ndb now i'm also pretty sure
you said
by migrating to cloud ndb i'd be
accessing cloud datastore
but didn't you just say we're migrating
to cloud datastore today
if i'm already on cloud datastore why
would you want me to migrate
to it i'm confused oh no no it's not
that
apologies for the confusion you're right
in both cases we're still on the cloud
data store database
but here we're talking libraries when
data storm assured to becoming its own
product
the google cloud team created a new
native client library for non-app engine
apps
that's also where we point python 3 and
other next generation app engine
runtimes
cloud ndb is made just for python 2 app
engine developers
today's migration is for those
considering that extra step
to going from cloud ndb to the cloud
datastore client libraries
okay i think i understand now you're
saying that there are
two client libraries to access cloud
datastore one for long time
python app engine users who prefer the
ndb style
and while the other is for those
completely new to cloud datastore
is that right yes essentially that's
right although cloud ndb can use with
the next generation and python 3 app
engine apps as well
as non-app engine apps meaning python
developers have two options for
accessing cloud datastore depending on
their preference
now the real question is why you would
consider migrating
yeah that's my point if both can be used
for app engine
and non-app engine apps why should i
even consider migrating
it'll require some effort without much
gain as since i'm not getting any new
features
and generally expect no changes to my
app yep that is absolutely correct which
is the main reason why this migration is
optional
if your older app engine apps uses cloud
ndb to access cloud datastore
and newer non-app engine apps use its
native client library and satisfy that
everything's working there's really no
need to change
the only reason you would consider it is
if your organization wants to
consolidate to a single client library
for consistency
shared across all of your apps it'll
reduce the size of your code base and
the one common library would become
robust
because it'll be used by many apps it'd
be fully featured fully debugged and
increased code reuse
this makes code across apps easier to
manage and lower maintenance costs
overall
however if that's not worth your effort
just stop now okay
i'll bite with let's say i want to do
that
or maybe i'll think about it and i want
to at least see what this migration
entails
all right sounds good okay everyone same
drill as before
copy your module 2 cloud ndb app code or
if you don't have it clone the repo and
download the zip file
the only decision you have to make is
whether you want to migrate the python 2
version of the app or python 3.
these are in the module 2a and 2b
folders
you can also migrate the python 2
version first then port it to python 3
which is how the codelab does it
we'll show you how to do both in a
minute but let's pause now so you can go
grab the code
and also pull up the code lab so you can
get hands-on experience with this
migration
all right let's go to the computer and
walk you through it
it's always good to start with a working
app from your python 3 module 2 folder
run gcloud app deploy to upload to app
engine if you're still in python 2
double check that flask and ndb are in
lib if not or you're unsure
it's fine to delete the lib folder and
reinstall then deploy
your motivation to upgrade to python 3
no more manual bundling
regardless when deployed point of
browser or curl to your app and confirm
the output is the same as from before
whether modules zero
one or two okay now let's migrate to
cloud data store
the best part about migrations is what
doesn't change
app.yaml and app engine config.py stay
as is
same goes for index.html in templates
for requirements.txt switch from
cloudndb to cloud datastore
also add versions here i left them out
of the video since version numbers
change all the time and also it's
different between python 2 and 3.
regardless the repo will be updated
unlike this video
ok python 2 developers must delete their
lib folders and reinstall now while
python 3 users can just chill
when done we can move on to the main
application file
at the top of main.py we're importing
and initializing the api client for
cloud datastore instead of cloudndb
we also have to add a new import for
datetime because cloud datastore doesn't
do automatic time stamps so we have to
do it
for store visit ndb acts more like an
orm or object relational mapper where
you declare a data model
instantiate an object with the desired
data then save it
on the other hand with datastore you
create an entity specifying its kind as
a key
you get back a dict like object to add
to your data as key value pairs
or in our case we merge an entire python
dictionary into it then save
there's also no context manager when
using cloud datastore
in fetch visit you can see querying is
similar but datastore is a bit easier to
read
ndb favors chaining methods together but
datastore has a more step-by-step
approach
plus the convenience of getting back
python dictionaries back without having
to do additional conversion like ndb and
that's all that's needed to migrate this
sample lab to cloud datastore
save gcloud app deploy and confirm it
still works just as before
right let's go back to the main
presentation
thanks for showing us that migration wes
it was good to see that cloud datastore
isn't that
different from cloud ndb of course
martin
it's true the code is similar but this
is a sample app
in real life there are likely more
challenges especially related to complex
queries
so i've linked to the queries pages for
both libraries so you can see more
differences between them
while i'm doing the codelab on my own
time i might need to see the cloud ndb
and cloud data store docs uh you got
those
links handy yep i thought you'd ask here
are the links to both the cloud ndb and
cloud datastore docs as well as through
their client library repos
finally we link to the app engine data
store docs don't forget the repo has
both the start and finish folders so you
can reset back to the 2a or 2b code
if you take a wrong turn during the
codelab or want to compare your answers
with
ours in the modules 3a or 3b folders by
the way
if you're still wondering whether to
choose cloud ndb or cloud datastore
here are our recommendations creating a
new app in python 3
app engine or otherwise go straight to
cloud datastore
got a python 2 ndb app engine app
migrate to cloud adb
then port to python 3. lastly if using
cloud datastore elsewhere and want a
consistent code base using only one
client library
consider this migration if not don't
bother because cloud adb works
in both python 2 and 3 with app engine
or outside of app engine so there's
really no need to move off unless you
have cloud data store code elsewhere
ah thanks wes that was really good
explanation that
it helps me make my decision by the way
on another note
i also heard that cloud datastore was
renamed
is that right all right yes martin uh
it's a bit more than that and i didn't
want to distract users from the main
content
but yes it's true the next generation
data store service launched in 2017
as it inherited some features from the
firebase real-time database
it was rebranded as cloud firestore
all existing datastore databases have
been upgraded under the covers to
firestore in datastore mode for new
applications consider using the cloud
firestore in native mode
we've given you a link to learn more
about when you would choose one over the
other
neither the cloud ndb nor cloud
datastore libraries however can access
those firebase features
you do really need to use the cloud
firestore client library
if you have an app app engine or
otherwise and at some point down the
road want to take advantage of those
firebase features
consider further migrating to cloud
firestore if interested
check out module 6. ah that's pretty
interesting
i didn't even know about cloud firestore
and i will take a look at that module
it sounds like another serverless
migration station episode we can work on
together
ah that'll be fun for sure now what
other migrations should you consider for
your app engine apps
if your app uses the original app edge
and task keys consider migrating to
cloud tasks
and check out modules 7 8 and 9. if
you're curious about containerizing your
apps
check out the app engine to cloud run
modules 4 and 5.
finally if your app engine app is simple
like our sample app consider migrating
to cloud functions
more on that in module 11. sounds like a
lot of options for users out there
happy to be working with you to help
guide our users and show them best
practices
was sounds good martin and that wraps
today's
optional migration to cloud data store
on behalf of martin and porter this is
wesley chun from google cloud and we
look forward to seeing you
at the next migration station or on
another serverless expedition
[Music]
soon
you